we all save our money in savings bank
accounts right
but why is it advisable to invest money
rather than just saving it
let's see
in india the money we keep in the
savings account will fetch us an
interest of around three to four percent
per annum now if we have 20 000 rupees
in our account we will receive 600
rupees as interest at the end of the
year
so what's the concern we're still making
money right well not really the
inflation rate in india is around five
to six percent per annum what's
inflation in simple terms it refers to
general increase in prices which leads
to decrease in the value of money so if
we consider inflation we notice that our
returns are not really positive
it has been reduced to nineteen thousand
six hundred rupees from twenty thousand
rupees
though it is difficult to see the power
of inflation in the short run it will
actually eat into a kitty in the long
run
now does that mean keeping money in a
savings bank account is bad
not really one should keep only an
amount which is required to carry out
daily activities like say maybe paying
bills or peer-to-peer transfers etc the
only way to escape from inflation is to
invest our money
what instruments can one invest their
money in read the first comment to know
more